James Brown host of the NFL today is
here with his predictions for the
matchup JB warning pretty obviously see
the dieting continuously looking better
and better well thank you so very much
without the Spanx suction painful bill
makes me blush even though I don't blow
sperm the end a match between Brady Tom
Brady and Matt or is it a question of
who has the best defense you know it's
both questions and of course the public
and the press will focus on the marquee
names but it's really about organization
New England is the best there is
I know I've worn this expression out but
in an era of design parity and a
National Football League they are the
dominant team and they get it done with
a system key players but a great talent
evaluator Bill Belichick is and it
starts at the top of Robert Corey Tom
Brady wasn't there for the first four
games Rob Gronkowski was out he looks so
sad by the way sitting in the box
yesterday watching him well because
Norah O'Donnell was there so Tom Brady
comes back and they go thirteen and one
and the guy is playing a game in
football vernacular we say the game is
moving slowly in front of him because
he's mastered it so well the unsung
heroes and Klaus to your guy here will
tell you this it starts in the trenches
you need somebody to protect them and
they get it done and their defense does
it collectively I mean Tom Brady just
seems to get better and better he threw
384 yards against the Steelers that's a
Patriots post season record and he kept
throwing to Hogan who was there a couple
times wide open if it isn't that speak
about the genius of Bill Belichick yeah
who would watch a guy talk about a
talent evaluator like Chris Hogan and X
lacrosse player but do you like some of
the intangibles that he brought to the
table and they get it done maybe if I
was listening to you I might not even go
there if I was the end lanta Falcon the
Green Bay Packers what you know was
missing their chance of misery they saw
the organization Brady's
and he has all the time in the world
golly you're good I was really she's
impressed you they're influenced you
blank is an excellent on a man people
root for him because he's a good guy
even going through the Michael Vick saga
he was there in cheering Michael Vick on
he's got a great offense there Matt Ryan
it should be the MVP and they've got a
lot of options as my producer Alvin
patrocle saying no no they are a
talented team but New England can get
inside your head before the game even
somebody got inside
Aaron Rodgers head yeah what happened
Aaron Rodgers I'd give them a little
credit because it just so happened to me
and Klaus may disagree with me Klaus
he's talking he's not the in force I
mean football on the line for Syracuse
they just ran into a better team so are
you expecting a good game speken go get
game because we had such flow out this
weekend you expect what are you
expecting as job we all want a great
game john madden agreed to football
coach is to say you know they don't play
the games on paper yeah see what happens
on the field on paper it should be a
good matchup the league's number one
scoring team against the defense that
allows the fewest points and you tell me
give me 1 stars name on defense for a
New England it's team orient you can't
think about it so on paper it should
right now the Patriots have the edge
though right oh absolutely make them a
couple of touchdown favorites I've never
predict a winner from a TV standpoint I
always want to see a competitive game or
Nora up in Bob crafts box absolutely you
know what Jersey I'll be wearing on
Super Bowl Sunday looking for honey
Gonzales sends the love - you're - yeah
I was thinking of him yesterday I'm so
excited he's not there yet
touch that one ok thank you very much
sir Thank You JB always good to see you
see you guys